did you ever think you make it I feel
I'm so I tastet Victory I know this life
for me yeah why would you bet on Goliath
when we got bet David value taming
giving values contagious this world
entrepreneurs we get no value to haters
how run homie look what I become I'm the
I'm the
one okay all
rise perfect fantastic we have we have
the Joe Brown in the house by the way
just want to
make we give respect I want to make one
thing very clear today's podcast is
probably not going to be for those of
you that are extremely sensitive you may
want to skip today's and go watch
something else go listen to a nice song
because this man uh doesn't have a
filter especially where he's at right
now he's willing to talk about he seems
to be willing to talk about anything and
doesn't hold back when he's given it let
me properly introduce to him to you his
bio so he he's professionally known as
Judge Joe Brown American lawyer and
television personality served as a judge
on shelin County Tennessee Criminal
Court from 1990 to '98 he's also known
for hosting the arbitration based
reality Court show called Judge Joe
Brown from 98 to 2013 if you've been on
YouTube you just Google his name there's
plenty of videos with 10 20 30 million
views and trust me you've seen it as a
judge Brown was known for his tough but
fair approach to Justice and he was
often praised for his ability to connect
with the people who appeared on his show
he was also popular figure among viewers
and his show was consistently won the
highest rated daytime television
programming Brown has received several
awards for his work including the NAACP
image award for outstanding legal civil
rights program 1999 20012 0304 and the
People Choice Award for the favorite
daytime talk show host O2 he's also
nominated for a prime time Emmy Award
for outstanding talk show 20002 2001 and
2002 he ran he ran as a democratic Prim
what was it won the Democratic primary
for the position of Shelby County
district attorney in
2014 and there's some very interesting
political opinions there but outside of
being a lawyer and a judge he's also a
poet and
one of the ones I want to read this is
just this is this is this is pure poetry
guys you know you're a scientist when
you start the the poem with DNA the best
DNA don't tell no lies about what's in
between your thighs the one and only
Judge Joe Brown how you doing yeah there
you go all right judge is in the house I
guess but hell I retired from that so
you know well uh actually you had to add
two more years on it being on the real
criminal B I had two years overlapping a
lot of did I miss it was it 2015 or 20
uh 20 2000 when I I got you okay I got
and I'm an independent now I can't stand
a Democratic party really what happened
what what caused you to change uh they
decided to be anti-am and anti-man and I
don't buy into that has it always been
like that no it wasn't uh something
happened they kind of got stuck over
there in that far left corner someplace
and they forgot about the working people
in this country when do you think that
happened judge uh cuz you ran as a
Democrat now you're I did I I it bothers
me
um somewhere in the last 55 years what's
happened is the country is switched over
into glorifying what I call dysfunction
and at some point it's just enough is
enough you've got to a thing right now
where they're trying to groom children
in school they're trying to install a
secular religion as the official
religion of the country people don't
have any cause any purpose anymore so
they want to give them one but in this
one it says you have no duty honor
obligation responsibility accountability
be what the hell you want to be just get
your freak on
and there you go but that's not
sufficient to keep people working now
when you say 55 years is it probably
closer to the last 15 years that it's
been no it's been working see I I
remember the class UCLA 1969 and I
remember what was being said back then
when people said we hate men for one
reason or another and men are the cause
of War so we're going to ruin this thing
for the men and get rid of masculinity
and you had this problem with Hollywood
when it was going broke in the face of
color television and you switch from two
movies every Thursday and Sunday every
week of the year and Hollywood was going
broke so they said let's ramp the fee up
from 50 cents to a buck and a half and
we will have one movie that stays in as
long as we can so let's attract the most
people by going to the lowest common
denominator promoting
dysfunction Ridiculousness and meanwhile
we propagandize the country to get rid
of manhood and that basically is what's
been happening and and by the way these
are some of the topics I got that I want
to talk about today one is family
feminism manhood politics over the last
50 60 years fatherless homes statistics
I have on how many single mothers we
used to have in the 40s versus 60s today
lbj's policies in 1965 maybe you have
some thoughts on that on what change
when he came out with that and then we
got destruction of the black family
masculinity lgbtq and a few other things
War on Drugs a little bit of that with
Nixon was that a good thing that they
choose the right enemy Michelle Obama
Kam Camala Harris Trump Biden and maybe
a little bit of San Francisco cleaning
up the streets this quickly there's they
got this new technology called g g shows
up streets of uh San Francisco clean up
very quickly so let's go to the
direction you were going okay the
direction you're going on what's changed
you said not he said 15 years he said no
not necessarily it's more like 50 years
right 55 was it 55 years judge is it is
it more policies was it more with a
intent what was the intent was the
intent because they were trying to
please everybody was the intent because
militia reasons was the intent political
what was the reasons why we've gone
through the transitions we've gone
through last 55 years okay the Johnson
Administration came up with a safety net
they had good intentions but people are
enterprising so when they saw the
opportunities that were presented they
went for them and instead of having a
safety net that dealt with rescuing
people from an untenable situation due
to the economic that they found
themselves faced with you got people
that said well instead of using this to
help me with my babies I use babies to
get that so I can help myself so you
have
multigenerational situations and even
back in the late 90s I had people in my
courtroom where there was six
Generations where nobody had had a job
ever I had one woman in my courtroom
starting in
1994 she had felony drug and theft
charges she was 57 she had a 43-year-old
daughter that was in front of me that
she had when she was 14 43y old daughter
had the same charges the 43y old
daughter had a 40 at a 34 year old
daughter born one week shy of her 10th
birthday who was in there the 34y old
had a 21y old daughter in front of me
the 21y old do uh daughter had an
11-year-old daughter please don't go L
who had the circumstance of being
pregnant with her second child no way
with her second child second child an
11year old sir uh yeah so I got the 21y
old back in about 14 15 months she was
23 her 11-year-old was 13 with three
children the 57y old was back in front
of me she was 59 and she had at that
point
342 lineal descendants we tracked and
then two weeks later after I got that
report she had
358 and between
1996 in 2000 when I retired exponential
increase she had more than 34 400 and I
had 120 plus of her people in front of
me in my
courtroom one way or another one of her
sons had 63 outside children by I think
59 different baby mamas and he was
6359 he's 29 yeah
sheez so I mean people don't even think
about this kind of thing and then we did
another study we found in the high
schools uh in the Memphis Area there
were maybe 35 or 40 core problems where
the students were much older than they
were supposed to be and they were
creating a negative culture for the
whole high school and we found out that
this woman that I had in my courtroom
and four others every single one of the
five that they had in
there uh that we were tracking was an
ancestor for every single one of the
kids in the high schools that were the
core of the problem so just total
dysfunction and the last we checked was
2008 it turned out these five women had
almost a quarter of a million people in
West Tennessee that were descended of
them and they were still
breathing safe to say that they've never
even heard of the word condom is what
you're saying yeah not only that but in
this group 3 400 that I wound up dealing
with before I retired in
2000 out of this family we found two
people that had had jobs and graduated
from high school and they were girls who
had essentially been kidnapped by their
fathers when their mothers went to the
penitentiary and got taken to Chicago
which then had a pretty good school
system so those were the only two we
could find but see there's a mass of
that out there so when you talk about
the impact what happened with the
Johnson Administration I don't think
they intended that but it happened next
thing we had in the late 60s we had the
individuals that hated that they weren't
men that's the feminists the ones that
hated men certain other lesbians the one
that hated that they weren't strong men
those were the beta boys some of the gay
ones that hated that they weren't normal
men and then you had the ones that
stacked on and gave the big ballast that
said were the cause of War man we need
to have love man that war war is a bad
thing man we need to get rid of all of
this toxic masculinity like fool where
do you think this is going to go so it
went there and they controlled the
communications media and you get what
you get right now where if you go on
Instagram Facebook YouTube you get this
Mass censorship where you can't say
anything that makes people feel uncom
comfortable oh my God he hurt somebody's
feelings oh hell a lot of people need
the feelings St on you know like dude
what's wrong with you come get grow
stronger but the judge you've been
you've been around when you're doing
meeting with all these families who what
part of the responsibility is Mothers
what part of the responsibil is on the
father because typically the blame goes
on the father well there are no fathers
and see the thing of it is these men
that just ran off and left the women
these women don't want the men all they
wanted was the babies and see you had
people like the poetress Nicki Giovani
back in the 60s were going all around
the country and they were lecturing the
women and they were young women and they
were saying you don't need a father for
your children just get preo find one
that looks good smart athletic yeah that
one and don't even tell him that he's
the daddy cuz if you bring a man into
the picture they screw up everything so
there was this point where if you had
the guy around there was a problem and
then there was some that did want the
guy around but back when I first started
practicing law 50 years ago one of our
number one cases was getting the check
cut back on because some ding bad social
worker would sit at the end of the block
with binoculars and if there was one or
two of the six or seven baby daddies
trying to play father that cut the check
off so we had problems with juvenile
courts around the country where judge
that's not my kid well you feeded long
enough uh he'll look just like you so
you know that was before DNA and I can
remember one thing I it was a cop I was
representing and he got a petition to
increase the child support So when they
called the kids's name I stood up he
stood up two more lawyers stood up and
two other guys stood up so this woman
was collecting child support from three
guys for the same kid so we finagled
getting some DNA testing and none of the
three were the daddies no way so I mean
you have these horror stories going on
that's some old school Jerry sir was
this mostly whites blacks Latinos what
both all of the above all of the above
the juvenile court C started privatizing
and acquiring jurisdiction it used to be
in Superior are circuit courts
so they became dysfunctional circuses
and a lot of them privatized and what
happens is you want to promote
dysfunction because that's business
Downstream now you know if you if you if
you tell this to U media won't talk
about what you're talking about right
now but people will say that's because
of systemic racism that's that's because
all of that's been the reason why we are
where we are right now judge because
you're being you're not being
compassionate to see the pain and the
suffering and the challenges Black
America experien it's because of the
systemic racism that we have what would
you say okay yeah get over it in other
words Buck it up you know it's adversity
the world's got adversity it always has
if it's not a tiger or a lion trying to
eat you it's this so face it become
prepared to deal with it stop looking
for excuses even if there are some don't
take them just say it's something to go
conquer I did something now one thing I
will say about this they have a habit in
this country of using black people as
guinea pigs so there is this anti-
masculine movement and back in the 60s
they perceived black men to be the most
overtly
masculine so let's attack them first if
we destroyed them and put them in their
place and black women know how to do
this well already then we we can make
this move up and then we can do stuff at
the top that'll filter down with the
propaganda so you unman the country
meanwhile the People's Republic of China
in January 2021 put an official ManUp
campaign in place and so did Russia some
years before now I will say this my
former in-laws or rather my former
daughter-in-law was a born in Russian
Russia but she was in the US Navy as a
translator so she was naturalized now if
you get what Putin is saying over there
to justify Ukraine it's the following
one the Tamp down resurgent Nazism
because it was rampant in Ukraine two to
do something
about the sex trafficking that's going
on over there there's overt sex slavery
in fact and three to save the country
from imposing the
lgbtq A+ cult on the rest of the world
now I was surprised um I do this xpace
now used to be Twitter and I
thought I was getting trolled by some
gays that were calling in but I was
surprised to find that they
were very much opposed lgbtq I as a cult
like somebody said well you can be
Islamic but that doesn't mean you
support Isis or Al-Qaeda or you can be
Christian that doesn't mean you
supported Reverend Jim Jones and
drinking Kool-Aid at large Church
picnics in Guyana you know so it's
like a lot of them have bad memories
about this exposure to pedophilia and
they don't like grooming and a lot of
folk are decent to say you should not
deal with children and sex in the same
phrase the same paragraph so we've got
these things and you have to understand
what we're facing from the way Putin
explains it is it's like a
religion now to understand that think of
Buddhism it's an old ancient honorable
Bel religion but there's no deity but
it's a system of philosophy so what you
run into with lgbtq UIA plus etc etc is
a system of philosophy that is being
imposed rapidly by the government it's
being crammed down the throats of the
kids and the people uh you can't put a
Christian cross under an American flag
on a government building you can't put
the Crescent the Jewish
star uh Hindu symbol or Buddha or
whatever it may be but you can put a
rainbow flag and you you can paint the
sidewalks in DC rainbow colors and you
can have government building with a
banner rainbow hanging down 11 floors
you see in other words the government
itself is imposing a religion that it's
not giving the citizen re a choice as to
whether the follow or not and as far as
the grooming of the children concerns
well some of us
remember uh if you don't go to church on
Sunday you can't go anywhere else the
rest of the week
well Mama may have taken you to church
mosque Temple synagogue whatever it may
be and you fell asleep after 45 minutes
or whatever it is but now from
kindergarten on you sit there for 6
hours a day and the teacher with Jangles
around her wrist and the Itsy Bitsy
Spider and all of that and then they've
got a rainbow flag on the wall
and they're teaching this to the kids 6
hours a day so I know I can remember
stuff that I learned when I was in the
second grade occasionally it'll flash in
the back of my head so I can just wonder
what some of these kids are going to be
thinking
in 70 years uh whatever it's I don't
like the picture because I don't care
what somebody does in their own bedroom
get your freak on that's your business I
mean do it as long as you're not sending
somebody to the hospital but yes sir
it's keeping in the damn bedroom when
somebody starts trying to bust down your
living room door and say I'm coming in
here with this nuh uh uhuh no and then
the other thing is is we have to deal
with manhood and rationality reason
critical thinking
objectivity and getting away from
emotionalism um when I was on a bench
toward the last few years why' you do
this young man I was emotional
would you please give the court a reason
for why you did this okay you were
emotional but what was your reason
you're asking the court not to send you
to jail and put you on probation but I
was
emotional what you know you started
getting this kind of nonsense where it
becomes uh a thing where the population
has been propagandized into
dysfunction I mean it's like see if you
going to have a healthy Community you
have to have a balance between what the
individual does and what the individual
obligates himself to when it comes to
the whole
Community um duty honor obligation
responsibility accountability
Duty devolving into courage and
elevating itself into bravery so that
what you are about is making where you
live a better safer more sec secure
place filled with economic Prosperity
opportunity all kinds of things public
peace dignity and Order where you are a
man of public peace who can be brave and
courageous when necessary when the
Titanic goes down you say ma'am you and
your child have my seat I'll drown with
the boat but nowadays some little fluffy
comes in here with a dress he wants to
sit down and say oh hell no get your ass
up I'm going to throw you over there
Chum the Sharks which you make everybody
else safe you know I mean really uh it
is not all right to be a coward uh we
used to hunt is our number one first
profession and if you're going to do
that you have to have somebody watching
your back your six so
that people would be willing to put it
on the line for each other that's
bravery and courage and now they want to
say whoa that's okay forget it it's okay
to be a coward I even ran into something
at one Library I just stumbled into I
walked in and they were conducting a
class with some kids about uh anti-hero
you don't want to be a hero being a hero
is bad like where the hell did these
fools come from hey judge can I ask you
a question so what what I want to know
what is the reason especially if the
government's involved and I saw what you
talked about but the the flag in front
of the White House and stuff what is
their goal for demasculinizing us why is
why are they pushing this this cult why
is everything you know everything is
lgbtq and they're a small small little
minority group but they are protected by
the government like what what is their
endgame it's a
religion just like Buddhism it has no
God but Buddhism deals with the positive
aspects of character but you see when
you confront somebody with hey you can't
do that you got to get up and be up
front you got to put it on the line uh
oh my God I might get hurt yeah that's
the name of the
game oh great hero he just sank a threo
pointer with four seconds left in the
game and the Lakers win by one point oh
come on that's not being a hero that's
what we think of it now you didn't put
anything on the line you got paid lots
of money for doing what a lot of people
do for recreation and exercise so what
is this where we deemphasize those
things that have kept us together that
have pushed the
Frontiers you see that's not going away
the sea levels are rising some say
though I went out here and I noticed it
in certain places in
Miami it's not where it was 35 years ago
it's a little higher so something's
going on I've noticed I used to have
place up in Aspen for about 10 15 years
and I noticed that the snow level is
dropping down in fact a few years ago I
put a marker on a ski lift uh pylon and
it kept inching
down foot by foot quite a few feet over
the years so something's going wrong and
the world is getting more populated and
resources are getting spse and this
thing about manhood is going to become
very valuable once again so what are you
supposed to do with all of that when
you've been training the boys to get
away from it because you see getting up
and giving up your seat on the Titanic
takes a lot of conditioning from Cradle
to whenever you happen to be found in
that situation so you're not going to
suddenly put that in oh man I'm not
getting up out of my seat you can go do
it you're equal go swim with the fish I
got my seat you know that
doesn't work sir one one followup to
Vinnie's question over there by the way
you're on fire right now please continue
what you're doing everyone loving this
right now I was holding back no if this
is holding back then uh continue sir um
the anti-hero the the metaphor to that
what would you say is a modern American
hero I like what you said about
basketball they're getting paid tens of
millions of dollars to sink a ball
what's a real American hero today the
only one can see Donald
Trump or your Governor here in
Florida you have people that make stands
but they want to make them Boogeyman and
enemies and that's the other thing find
a boogeyman the babayaga so you can go
after him rather than expose the
platform that you have as being weak um
the Democratic party used to be the one
that protected the worker now they're in
the back pocket for high finding you've
got a weird situation with the
interwoven family setups even the stuff
that's not uh obvious there's a
gentleman by the name of Sam hinley Sam
hinley was an indentured servant he was
a Hugo Frenchman who wanted to get away
from Catholic persecution so he
indentured himself came over to the
Americas well he seems to have prospered
and he had seven US presidents that are
his direct lineal descendants one vice
president and a whole bunch of
billionaires the most recent you can
think of is George Herbert Walker Bush
George Walker Bush Barry storo Barack
Obama and Dick Cheney they're all
cousins yeah so
it's when you look at that uh Sam hinley
late of K pad it's been a while back he
was one of those people at 3 fifths of
the number of which in article one were
to be counted toward portioning
representation in the house part of the
three- fifths compromise yes so some
people think they call black folk
three-fifths of a human but they don't
even mention color in the Constitution
this says for purposes of
apportionment three FS of all people in
slavery or involuntary servitude shall
be counted toward that
number now that's what they're doing to
a great extent with the
[Music]
illegal
immigrants the last census we had in
2020 is the first of the five that I
participated in as an adult where they
did not ask you your
citizenship the other ones they asked
not only were you citizens they wanted
to know if your parents were and how
they became citizens the reason they
aren't interested is because if you
don't get to ask that then you get to
count them in overall tally so when it
comes time to a portion Congressman or
members of the House California New York
Illinois and a few places don't lose
repres entation they gain it because
they get counted but they can't vote so
that allows the farle to impose their
programs based on numbers of people that
are not
being allowed to vote though New York
for example is trying to allow illegals
to vote in local elections and you'll
see the result of it very shortly when
you go through an airport you'll have to
have that star in the upper corner of
your driver's license to indicate that
there was a check to see that you in
fact were a citizen or what your status
was because California bunch of idiots
out there said uh we'll give it to the
illegals because we want to make sure
they can pass a driving test so forget
about what you do for the rest of the
country where nobody's ID is going to be
valid unless they re get a reissued one
but you see that's that balance
individual versus what the individual
owes to the collective so it's Devil
with the collective that's the bad part
of it these days Tom y you know by the
way thank you for that I've been
listening to this and you're on fire you
may not you say I'm just getting warmed
up you're absolutely on fire you said
something and I want to know if you saw
it because you are so perceptive and
you're so precise in what you're talking
about here in so you were at UCLA 1968
69 65 through 73 got it well 1969 we
know what happened there it was the
summer of love and you had the Vietnam
war protest against Johnson uh Johnson's
not going to run again and women's lib
blew up and all that happened if there
was a place where rebelling against
Society started in the US then Berkeley
was the Wuhan lab in 196 Berkley was
crazy did you see it you were there in
the middle of and you're a young guy
getting a a high education you're going
to go into law what did you see I didn't
want to go into law I wanted to go into
physics okay well still you're an
incredibly smart guy and perceptive what
did you see at that time that you said
wow if this keeps up we're in trouble or
if this keep did you see some tipping
points I didn't think we were going to
be in trouble because it took a spin
that I had not anticipated and I only
vaguely recognized at the time and
that's what Hollywood did with it
because they had an agenda they were
trying to push and they took advantage
of circumstances and did it now what
went on is we
had civil rights but civil rights got
people used to the idea
of large groups of people coming out and
doing stuff before that when you got
large groups out typically it had
something to do with a union matter or
employment or something like that or
workers of the World Unite yes and all
of that and you had these kinds of
things but you had it glamorized and you
had it covered in real time by
television which was not what you had
before so the idea of a bunch of people
being out somewhere carrying on because
they didn't like something was
publicized and put in the heads of just
about
everybody so that set the stage for
large scale protest and anti-war protest
and such like because the Nom was a very
unpopular
War now people look at stuff like the
January 6 thing where 180
people permitted what 50 years ago would
have been such a small blip nobody would
have paid attention to
it uh you had situations in DC 50 years
ago all around the country where you got
15 20 30 40,000 people breaking stuff up
you had the uprisings in the large
cities
where disenchanted people burnt the
place down I remember 65 August standing
on a lowrise hill in Los Angeles and I
pivoted
360 and you couldn't see the sun because
the smoke was so they looked like being
in a war zone this was the original
Watts Riots right
and that kind of
thing is something that today's people
don't get what they call a protest was
just people got bored and came out and
didn't have anything else to do with
trying to get laid you know
but nowadays um
it's a sense of proportion uh we
lost maybe somewhere around 5,000 folk
over in the sand pile over a 20 some
year
period I hate it but that used to be a
weekly tally back in the
60s see everybody in America knew
somebody that was dead from the N mhm
uh and we had people around that were
vigorous young and they had been in
Coran some people that were not even
getting too gray been in World War II
and then the grayhair folk had been in
World War one so there was a great deal
of difference about what folk felt they
were entitled to then and then you were
feeling entitled to the opportunity
to do for yourself now people have this
idea that the entitlement is somebody
doing it for you Cradle to
grave uh remaining in the Cradle you
make a great point about demonstrations
I mean you compare January 6 to Kent
State Kent State demonstration got so
bad and so rowdy they called the
national guard shot four unarmed
students and broke it up I mean they
shot more than four armed students but
that's how many died yeah and that you
look at January 6 and you look at the
60s you look at 1968 after in in Detroit
you know the conventions on the inside
and there's a mass demonstration
extremely violent on the outside and
it's not people without opinion but it
was so different yeah uh you got 28,000
people involved in that thing in Chicago
in 1968 with the democratic
convention uh I remember at UCLA where
we had a student Bob
60 65,000 full-time students and there
were some occasions when LAPD swept
through there and there were just
continuous riots going on over hours in
this complex with 60 some thousand
people being there so what people call a
big upset now we just looked at all what
else is what happened in the news you
know well that of the
I mean really what happened was
interesting sir you you said to yourself
that you describe yourself as a
registered independent you sound very
much like a republican why would you
just say that you're a republican the
reason I'm going to say I'm a republican
because I'm dissatisfied with them
they've gotten so far deep into this
thing where they want to be old time me
they are not taking the opportunity to
go and reach out to The Working Man like
they are too they are getting too much
into trying to hang on to Mitt Romney I
used to call him Mick
wrong oh the Rhinos you're talking about
not the mag class yeah and they need to
go about the business of saying hey stop
trying to be nice damnn it the public
doesn't want everybody to be nice that's
just what you hear see you've got a
Cadre the trans population Which is less
than a half% nationally the lesbian
population Which is less than 1%
nationally the gay population Which is
less than one and a half% nationally and
about four to 4 and a half% that dabble
both ways that puts the ballast in
that's maybe 6 and a half 7% 7 and a
half depending upon Where You Are but
Walt Disney the news media they want to
make you think that 60% of the country
is that way and they propagandize people
so that if it makes someone feel
uncomfortable or if it doesn't deal with
the popular perception something's wrong
with you well nothing's wrong with you
about saying hey uh everyone has to have
restraint be cool about this you know
they don't understand the phrase be cool
man you know no that's not cool what are
you doing chill but they don't get it
they've got gangster hip hop rap video
that is spread around the world because
you've got a lot of young males who see
no masculinity and they want to see it
and gangster hip
hop video puts out an image that looks
strongly masculine when it's not see
what you see in the Gang to rap
video is female
ideation you've got street
cred somebody that's never seen a real
man before he is ideating on the value
system of his favorite 13year old Aunt
when he was 9 years old and he heard her
talk
about drugs thievery wrongdoing and
finding somebody the opposite sex to
live off of young man if the Court's
disposed to place you on probation would
you please advise the court as to how
you're going to sustain yourself huh
well how are you going to earn a living
yo Yan is like this I got four ladies
take good care of me two of them got
good J OBS one get a crazy check and the
other one get afdc they takes care of me
okay so you ideate about being a jiggalo
what do you do huh I smooth them no what
do you
do see and that's not masculine ideation
that is the feminine stuff now back in
the mid 70s I used to run the public
defender office in
Memphis
and I would go out and interview a lot
of the defendants who were too lazy even
though they didn't have a job to take
the bus go downtown to see the
lawyer and I'd walk into a kitchen in
the projects and there
[Music]
are the
following people two 13y old females a
15y old two 16 year olds a 19y old and a
20 yearold the 19yearold was the client
and there about 15
young children from three to seven or
eight the older ones should have been in
school but they weren't they smelled bad
cuz they hadn't had a bath in a long
time dried food all over their clothes
mucus all over their faces they hadn't
been wiped and washed in a while and uh
my client and her friend girls are
cussing at them using the NW go get me
my cigarettes get me a beer and you just
like your no good damn daddy blah blah
blah blah blah and I'd say why you
talking to your child like that what's
the matter with you well he ain't
nothing but so and so and so and then I
got a shock then when I said well why
are you in here you're only 13 I'm
trying to have a conference with she can
stay and get your boy off the back there
and I said that's your child so the two
13 year olds had three of the children
that were running around out of control
that they were theirs I was used to
saying something like that where it's an
aunt trying to act like she's playing
mama not the 13-year-old being a real
mama now fast forward some
years
um got a 78 year old in his
1976 let's go to 19 1986 he's uh 17 now
all right 1996 he's
27 2006 he's 37 2016 he's
47 and he's going on 50 something now
you see so you've got this long
generational thing of this function back
up a few
years uh ma'am you're here as a witness
for the offending so and so and so and
his petition to suspend sentence is that
correct aren't you familiar to the court
for some reason yes Jana how does the
court have occasion to be having that
recollection well you with a public
defender at the time and you came to my
house I remember that you lived in the
projects over in foot homes right yes I
did what did the court tell you well you
said
something was going to go wrong if I
didn't change this now this is your
great grandson we're dealing with here
but it's only been 25 years how do you
get great grandson out of that you know
and we were talking about some kid that
wasn't but what
seven that's right Johor so wasn't you
know it's like this dysfunction is just
bad
now excuse ex me would you say that
again to the court you're here to speak
on behalf of this individual for
sentencing he's got an especially
aggravated rape case because he
impregnated a
13-year-old 12y
old
and you say you invited him into your
house what's going on well my friend
girls were telling me that I got a grown
woman in my house ain't no reason why we
ain't getting another check for that so
you took this 27 year old and moved him
into your house to knock your 12y old
daughter but we needed to check wow
that's a business model take her into
custody no bond on being an accessory to
especially aggravated rape wow so so so
here's my here's my challenge where I'm
at I've been listening to you for an
hour and I can listen to you for three
more three more hours I got four
questions here for you based on what you
just said on this one here here this
specific story Let's uh isolate this one
here this to me is a this wouldn't
happen if the incentives we had in
America didn't incentivize her friends
to tell her you got a woman here that
can get pregnant at 12 13 years old that
you can get a check that's a business
model that's the doing of bad policies
that FDR and LBJ created that caused
single mothers in America to increase
from 1940 when it was only 4% to now 40%
and by the way
wor 40% Nationwide not not the different
sex can you pull up the chart that says
by different nationalities Rob not this
one we'll go to that one as well that's
fantastic go to the one you just showed
first one so this is where we were at
before 4% growth of unwet childbearing
in us from 29 to 13 it's always been
around 4% you got FDR does this thing
doesn't move a lot LBJ 65 does war on
poverty begins boom Skyrock is to 41%
now go to the other one Rob that you got
the one I texted you that shows U that
one oh right there that one if you can
zoom in a little bit if you could this
is from CDC non-marital birds in
us non-marital okay there you go
fantastic thank you okay so if you look
at this whites it's red so go to the
left on uh red in 1940 it's around 3%
that's come up right to where it's at
now 20% or So 20% or so if you go to
blacks it us used to be around 15
177% in 1940 that's come up to 70 plus%
in America and look at the skyrocketing
on when it happens 1965 just go straight
to 65 boom Skyrocket I don't have any
problem with that I think it's
conservative actually there are some
papers that the Pentagon issued in 2011
that have some higher figures than that
they said one of our problems with
recruitment is we can make you
physically strong but we can't make you
mentally tough because you need fathers
in the home place in order to make you
mentally tough we are not getting that
they said right now all Races considered
in the United States 42% of the
Americans 35 and under were born out of
wedlock that's what they were saying uh
20 that's 12 years ago they also said
and when you came to those 20 and under
it was 82% of the people in the country
were born out of woodlock so the
pentagon's figures are higher than that
watch this now go to the other chart
that shows amount of money we invested
to fight poverty so go to the left the
blue versus the red the blue is
percentage of individuals who were poor
by the official poverty standard go to
1947 all the way to the left you'll see
around 35% okay so FDR comes out with
his plans trying to minimize poverty in
America the red if you look at the top
right total mean tested welfare spending
in billions of constant $22 okay you you
notice the red up until 1965 it's not
that big of an investment but the
poverty is coming lower and lower from
30 this is after depression so we go
from 35% to 25% to 15% we come down to
10% but the cost skyrockets after LBJ
goes Higher and Higher and Higher and
guess what happens to Poverty it stays
around the 12 13 14 15% rate but the
amount of money now that we owe and that
we're spending taxpayers are paying for
this a plan that that never worked we
had 60 years of data to show us it's a
failed proposition and what community
did LBJ destroy the most the
African-American Community this is when
you look at policies and and the reason
why I bring this up with you is because
when I listen to you for first hour had
nothing to say I'm just listening to you
I'm watching you watching you and I
watch I've consumed so much of your
content just listen to what you have to
say a lot of logic a lot of reason
you're challenging you're pushing you're
kicking ass you're you're you're
challenging the young to get their act
together together you're challenging men
you're not holding all the
accountability on men you're putting it
on women as well who told you to get
pregnant that was your choice it's not
only the man that did it why did you do
it but to me at the most basic level
that we as America can control I can't
control if somebody's going to be the
DNA don't tell no lies about what's in
between your thighs right I can't
control sence that I can't control
science I can't control what people are
going to do but what I can control as an
American voter and somebody that wants
better policies is the incentives need
to be eliminated to pay welfare and
child support for people to continue to
have kids because what's happening is
moms are being incentivized to allow
their daughters to get raped because of
these policies if the law is true that
under 18 it is rape mothers because of
the tax system are allowing their
daughters to get raped by grown men just
to get a check and that to me is a
catastrophe
and the fact that our politicians and
leaders are not talking about it it
irritates me like you don't even know so
for me those who have already screwed up
those kids lives that's permanent damage
that ain't going away you know how it is
when damage is I have damage in a
different way I lived in Iran for 10
years you have damage in a different way
boys in the hood you said when you grew
up that was your life that's where you
yeah so but but moving forward if we
don't get our act together this shit's
going to continue and some innocent kids
today while they're watching the show
some innocent kids are being taken
advantage of by grown men yeah and let
me tell you something else too it's
gotten so bad about the emasculation
there's another stat in there that's
crazy 25 and under there are more boy
virgins than there are girl virgins in
America boys ain't even getting laid
Yeah one third of all men under 30 have
not been laid in the last year don't
know how to get a piece of ass you
you it's like damn me you should the
seriously I mean I'm not on the bench I
ain't running for anything right now but
uh look here too old anyway look here
this problem with emasculation has
gotten out of hand because 50% of the
human race is one gender and the other
50% over here and The Fakes you know
that's not even half a percentage point
but uh you got to understand that
there's an equality of value but there's
not an equality of circumstance there's
some things women can do that men don't
do so well and vice vers you know that
emblem for
yinyang where they've got the white D
raindrop over here women can do a little
bit men do a lot here and vice versa
that's a reality
the yingang yeah but people don't want
to deal with that and what's going on is
when you start trying to subtract half
of the human race from the equation you
get hell it doesn't
work uh this feminist thing is
crazy um my motto is protecting
Womanhood and promoting manhood so that
works but when you start saying we're
going to destroy manhood you got a
problem when you have have a 50-year
history of take your daughter to work
week as an official event and not one
single day to take your son to work you
have a problem we have something else
going on right now and this comes from
the Pentagon and other sources too right
now for the last 20 some years of this
Century on average only 28% of each
Year's high school graduates are male
only 32% of each Year's undergrad crop
is male only 36% of the grad students
are male and only 44% of the workforce
is male something has gone way damn
wrong with that picture and you have
this continued emphasis especially from
the uh Democratic party about female
this female that this that other we got
to go recruit this and and like what is
happening with the boys and the last I
check the girls aren't doing the driveby
see when you get the clown shooting up
the schools and everybody wants to say
it's gun oh my God no you can do
somebody in with a rock I've been taking
martial arts for 55 years and I'll kill
you with my bad hands and there's a
bunch of lethal Weaponry around here I
see a lot of it I take you out on even
the books remember John W episode yeah
you can do that with the books so I mean
it's character and people have to get
back to there is no substitute for
building character you have children and
you don't know what to do with them you
don't know how to raise them it's just
like training puppies if you take people
puppies or dog puppies and you don't
know what to do with them they grow up
to be unruly adults so you have to be
able to handle what you have but we
don't want to put that out there because
oh my God somebody may be infringing on
what somebody wants to do and oh we have
to get rid of guilt and shame guilt and
shame are good they're self-control
devices put somebody in a condition of
Shame hey that's crazy but then again
people aren't used to this either
anymore the churches the mosque the
synagogues nobody talks about Sin it's
all all about
belief so you believe you get to heaven
or Paradise or whatever not behave
correctly because that's difficult that
requires work you got to forbear on
something no I'm going to hold off on
that instant
gratification uh inquiring minds want to
know right
now you know we get the Press pushing in
on this we get people unable to resist
development of some hey you don't get
this overnight you have to work at this
it doesn't come automatically you'll go
out and spend a lot of time in a gym
trying
to get buffed what for you don't know
cuz you don't have a damn job where you
need it which you're just working around
trying to look pretty about it even the
girls do this nowadays but nobody
understands the correlation between work
out and work anymore unless you happen
to be a profession profal athlete or
somebody that aspires to be one um what
what have you put in people's heads
about heroics there are no American
Heroes now you have
uh Hollywood Heroes but they're just
fake they aren't going out and charging
a Machine Gun Nest or going and rescuing
a hostage for real that's play that's a
script that's special effects uh you get
the real live war heroes and we treat
them like their when they get back
here nobody wants to be bothered with it
you got a situation where our damn fool
military is spend more money cutting
dicks off than they are and buying M
proofed Vehicles just look at vinck yeah
hey you take a rhino vehicle uh mind
proof vehicle aside from the fact that
the damn thing's 11 ft tall and makes a
hell of a tank Target with a perer enemy
um about half million dollars
unequipped but by the time you cut
somebody's dick off on a six-year
sentence of which he spends four years
getting operations and
Rehabilitation you have lost the price
of two fully equipped rhinos which would
have six people to 11 people per vehicle
that's 12 to 22 Young Americans that are
risking mutilation and death because
somebody wanted their dick cut off you
know what the hell is that about and I'm
sorry I got to talk about it that's just
crazy we do not need to be pushing that
and that's another one of these things
about what happened to building
character you're supposed to be in the
home place but it's not but it's
supposed to be reinforced by society
which it's not it's supposed to be
something that gets caught in school
which it is not supposed to be shorten
the religious institutions which it is
not and so what the devil is going on
the rest of the world is being character
are developed we are not look at what
happened two weeks ago all
the Publications dealing with economics
were noting that China is now officially
the wealthiest nation in the world they
stabilize all of the world's currencies
all of the world's stock exchanges they
have the fastest computer system in the
world they've got 80% of the world's
manufacturing capacity uh hell why new
why learn English now you might as well
learn Mandarin Chinese if you want to
deal with what's going on so we're
giving that up we're just like Great
Britain was a hundred years ago they got
aett I said you know it's just not
spotting you know and nowadays they're
third world country every one of their
former colonies Pakistan India are
militarily more powerful
Australia Canada you name it they've got
nukes and they've got some crazy James
Bond types but that doesn't really make
up for the fact we're on that same kind
of slide how did that happen though you
you given the stat because uh the number
was were I I I can pull it up whether it
was ' 80s or the '90s where they went
from being 86% Brits to now only 38%
Brits because
they've taken so many refugees and
they've taken so many immigrants coming
in that they're losing the identity of
what it once was damn it I've been
paying 30 years worth of my life to try
and deal with making the law work and
then you sit here and you award people
for criminality sneaking into the
country and you're Expediting green
cards and you're giving them subsidies
and you got a huge homeless problem no
character in your own public what the
hell is going on here I'm all for
immigration if it's legal come in the
right way follow the damn law I was here
with my now ex-wife some years ago in
Miami
airport and I remember somebody based on
the prompting of somebody that worked
for security TSA there they just
happened to be evil they told him to
walk up some stairs to the side when you
come in I know my wife knew knew uh that
you don't go up there but they told them
to go up there was a young couple white
couple wound up when the alarm went off
the guy got thrown uh up against the
wall elbow to the back of the neck they
threw him there the young girl got
thrown down on the ground her sundress
flipped up she had a thong on and a bear
ass is showing
everybody uh I mean it really ran
through the make H her so you treat
American citizens like if they look
like they're going to do an infraction
and then you say come right on in what
the hell you know Isis and Al-Qaeda are
probably drooling at the idea so what
are we supposed to do with this how much
of this you think is affirmations
language words heroing machine meaning
you're you're not a uh uh you know
certain word that is used by different
communities you're not a fan of it
because you don't seem to be a fan of it
because not words have a lot of power
right so if I'm listening to
affirmations and it's okay if you want
to be a girl it's okay if you want to be
a boy maybe you're a boy stuck in a
girl's body maybe you're a girl stuck in
a boy's body you don't have to tell your
parents it's okay you're different it's
totally fine honey it's okay sweetheart
all these words that are being fed over
and over and over words have power how
much of the consequence of where we are
today is these a affirming words being
heard from social from mainstream from
education from teachers how much impact
you think these words have had on kids a
whole hell of a lot we used to spend a
lot of our time recreationally doing
what we call running the dozens hey man
I don't want to say nothing man but your
mama man I was by there last night man I
didn't me etc etc that used to be fun
see but we used to get on other folk uh
like what's wrong with you man you some
kind of freak
man what's the matter with you but oh my
God they shame someone the police need
to be involved you talking about
somebody eight years old you want the
police to come down cuz eight-year-old
made another one feel bad hell they need
to learn how to deal with a bully
situation oh my God we can't have that
we must bring in the faculty and the
students you have to be protected by the
police they're only seven years old for
goodness sakes beat somebody's ass and
learn how to deal with man it up learn
how to fith uh Back to the Future
remember McFly went back taught his dad
how to deal with he knocked Biff out and
when he comes back Biff works for him
instead of bullying him they forget that
I mean and all these freaks that are
shooting up the hallways they all
universally had a problem with dollying
they didn't know how to deal de with it
and they got taught it was all right not
learning there's something about
screwing up your character and say man
this dude is big I might get whipped for
what the hell bam you know okay and at
least he knows with a busted up up time
next time it's going to cost him so you
screwed up your courage you feel yeah
that's all right you know I got a black
eye but hell I stood up you feel better
about yourself for the rest of your life
and you keep doing that this little
sissification of the country is
ridiculous it goes absolutely nowhere
and you've got girl up fools
masquerading as men in the Hood shooting
that up and you've got gir up fools that
don't know how to be men shooting up the
hallways so you want to control the
violence in the society you teach
masculinity because masculinity imposes
on the boy as he grows up just something
he can't escape from where he feels
massive guilt and shame if he cannot act
in in a masculine fashion which is you
don't do this at the wrong time wrong
place you have perspective you do not
beat on women you do not shoot your
neighborhood up you do not kill your
neighbors you do not poison them you
don't rape them you don't Rob them you
don't burglarize them you don't sell
poison to them what the hell's the
matter with you
you see when you take this out of the
equation where you get rid of character
then you got a problem but you see
character
requires
restraint
application dedication it requires
something where you got to go work at it
but you see everything's supposed to be
handed to you oh my God I want this so
badly well it's not just a courtesy here
you're entitled to it uh you don't have
to do anything about anything to get
this it's all supposed to be yours this
welfare state thing you're talking about
that leads in which goes back to another
thing I could become a republican if
they did a few things these days to
getting their acts together stop punking
out and trying to go fly over here where
you're going to try to reple the people
that ain't going to do for you
except get you to lose what you got
going you have boss Trump there who
somebody is looking at is saying I like
that guy cuz he stands up I don't care
if he's wrong or right he stands up what
the hell somebody needs to do it talk
back to these idiots I don't care if he
sounds like he is being crude I want to
hear that every now and then you know I
cuss when I get in the locker room or
around my homies or around my friends
whatever so what the devil this is
reality so let's get some more like that
and stop trying to get into we have to
distance ourselves from what the hell is
she got going you see you got a good
policy but nobody wants to hear that
because you've been part of this thing
where everybody's supposed to have five
second sound bites 15 second sound bites
and some somebody spent 27 years trying
to learn reading a whole lot of books
and doing a lot of research is supposed
to be condensed to 15 seconds ladies and
gentlemen we have today blah blah blah
and then they don't give you the news
they give you an editorial I remember
when news used to be a public service
thing until CNN screwed it up 35 years
ago and it became
247 after they got rid of the first Gulf
War there wasn't that much news and you
had idiots around Chuck what do you
think's going on here I don't know Errol
maybe what we have is maybe there are
some uh suspects in that cabin that's
burning everybody's looking at his
goddamn thing smoking you're looking at
the same thing well Chuck what if it was
so and so Tommy what do you think well I
don't really know but maybe it's godamn
it shut
up let's see what the hell happens you
know damn what's wrong with you that's a
goddamn burnt cabin okay now you don't
know anything more than I do so shut up
I don't want to hear you speculating on
this crap what it used to be uh and
that's the news for the day you've got
12 minutes they interrupted ordinary
programmer will'll be back to if there
are any new developments let's get back
to that I don't want to hear this
now we to with weather yes and so judge
how do you feel now that you know uh
with all you know the podcast and you
know X all these different platforms
that we could hear the news you think
it's a breath of fresh share because now
all the mainstream media companies are
going down all CNN is is losing
viewership by the minute Fox is you know
not doing well all their you know Tucker
Carlson leaves and goes to X and has a
massive viewing how do you feel about
the fact that now we can actually hear
the news and not have it censored I like
that the other thing too is news isn't
necessarily nice and see that's the
effeminization I want happy news well
God damn it go read a comic book
wouldn't be news if was nice hell
you think that's one of the reasons
judge where why Trump was such well is
still such a shock to them and to the
system because like you said judge he
don't give a he from day one from
videos that I remember as a kid from the
late 80s and 90s he was Pro Amer he just
didn't he didn't give a damn until he
became president then it's you know he's
racist and all that crap but he was that
alpha male not giving a not
apologetic and he came into a system
that did not like that yeah see racism
is a form of xenophobia of not W to
embrace the unfamiliar every single
human I have encountered has had
something negative to say about somebody
that's natural you try to act like you
don't You A Goddamn liar cuz you unless
you a saint maybe up in the Vatican or
something and I don't even buy
that but consider we all got negative
stuff to say like Adam's an we
all know that so yeah so bottom line is
is okay I remember back in the early 90s
Trump used to go into the nightclubs
with no security and hang with everybody
y he was liking black girls too
everybody uh I mean yeah so I don't have
any problems with him hell no well look
what he did with the uh Central Park 5
yeah well one of them's Daddy brought
him down to confess and implicated the
other four and they confessed what the
hell it was some pretty horrible
criminal activity that went on so yeah
people would talk about that I see all
of the folk right now oh is just so hard
well what the hell did you just get
through saying about
this huh well you said it you talking
about how horrible it was look what you
claimed it did to George Floyd I
supposed it came out another kind of way
you know botom blind so he just did what
you did so what's the problem you can't
look in the mirror you know you got anox
or whatever the hell they put on these
days didn't work and you got complexion
problem you know you don't want to see
yourself and then then then the other
one is objectification of beauty is
horrible no it
ain't if we didn't objectify Beauty we'd
still be looking something like a
chimpanze as hell Rob can you pull up
that clip when Trump trump is talking to
a lawyer and says like she was on my T
like you to be honest with you I would
never date you you're not brutally
honest have you heard 100% inos yeah in
the deposition but but I want to ask
this question from you so as a person
who is a uh is this the one where he
says that if it is you go ahead and play
that you say Marlo's in this photo
that's Marlo yeah that's that's my wife
which one woman are you pointing to no
here
Carol that the person you just pointed
to was Carol
Point your wife she's not my type and
that's 100% true she's not my
type say you're not Mye neither if you
can find that Rob but you know that's
reality yeah there's nothing wrong with
that so but you as a as a judge right
you've been in this system for a long
time right yeah it is so 91 counts 91
and they're trying to take him down and
lawyers and Lati know you know what's
going on in New York all this stuff from
somebody that's been in the space how
much of this is valid of what they're
doing how much of it is just absolutely
Justice
getting you're saying it's no
let how much of it is how much
of it is let me let's give you
a real quick analysis okay let's take
what's going on with uh stormmy Daniels
he supposedly bribed stormmy Daniels
to uh remain quiet and not embarrass him
well obviously brag the prosecutor
didn't pay attention in the first year
of law school when he would have been
taught to flip the script if you have to
pay somebody to not embarrass you you
got blackmailed that's a felony so
somebody got indicted for being the
victim of a felony blackmail effort all
right let's say the corporation got
indicted for not accurately reporting on
their forms which are public record
record why they paid stormmy Daniels
what they did well there was a gag order
in
there uh nobody was supposed to tell so
if the corporation had told they would
have violated the uh
confidentiality aspect of the settlement
all right let's get down here where
we're talking about the boxes of
documents the case is United States
Department of Navy versus Egan EG G
1888 there are a number of concurring
opinions and when you take all of them
you say to yourself oh the Supreme Court
is saying that since the president is
commanderin-chief of the armed services
and also Chief Diplomat for the United
States under the
Constitution he has absolute Authority
and discretion to classify or declassify
any document he wishes in any form shape
or fashion he chooses partially or
totally and also Marberry versus Madison
oh that was
1803 what is that
[Music]
220 years ago it says that if Congress
passes a law that is
unconstitutional it has no force and
effect so what we have is a set of laws
Congress pass it impune the president's
Constitutional Powers so they would have
no effect so the bottom line is is if he
removes the documents from the White
House then he has de facto Declassified
them in one sense in any form shape or
fashion he chose so what happens is the
White House was guarded by the Secret
Service malgo was guarded by the Secret
Service so what the hell is the
difference he doesn't turn it over to
the archivist well Marberry versus
Madison would suggest that the law that
required that he do that was
unconstitutional as imping his
constitutional power and authority and
it may be that certain of the things in
these documents were incriminating to
certain persons who if they got their
little grubbies on them would try to
destroy the records meanwhile let's talk
about something else that's associated
since I've actually read the downloaded
transcripts of the three laptops Hunter
Biden left it was three not
one and there is clear
discussion in these emails between the
vice president and his crackhead son
about taking your guys by the place and
looking at the Box behind the vets and
there are 42 apparent visits where they
go to see what's behind the vet and the
vice president is not protected by that
constitutional Authority and since
Congress decided to go after boss Trump
after he was no longer president and
they set the president for being able to
go after the former vice president for
what he did then and I would suggest
under Article 2 Section four that is
adequate grounds for impeachment which
they did not have
when they went after Trump either time
they did not cite in their articles
anything that was constitutionally
permissible to consider now let's get
back to what's going on in Georgia now I
won't talk about the lady too badly
since she's the daughter of a good close
personal friend I went to law school
with who used to be a militant but I
won't talk about him or his daughter but
let's just say uh when I downloaded the
90 two page
indictment one of the several things
that stuck in my mind was counts that
wanted to make it a felony for Trump to
Advocate to his followers to read or
view Newsmax now when in the hell in
America did it become a crime to
somebody read the news somewhere else
okay yeah so we get on with these kind
of things and the Civil thing here in
New York
uh that they're going on now I think is
a complete Forest because there is one
big phrase that's been left out of here
quote
business practices unquote the business
practice that is clear from all the
testimony is that the banks and the
financial institutions were aware of the
way people assess items they did not
lose any money on it
they knew what to expect it was as per
the industry it was a business practice
and the stupid idiots that's the
prosecutor Authority up there don't seem
to be aware of that and I submit that's
C in law school they didn't pay
attention business practices and they
should have been should have been
dealing with all the crooks running
around New York instead of trying to say
I'm going to protect America from this
evil B
and we're going to go try and deprive
the country now if you want a
constitutional crisis put it with 50%
40% or 30% whatever the public saying
what the hell do they think they're
doing I wanted to vote for the man now
these clowns are trying to keep me from
getting the chance to cast my vote what
the hell that's illegal that brings back
this thing of you want January 6 to
really be shown how insignificant it was
whoa let's go there but then let's get
back to January 6 he supposedly told
Pence don't sign this
okay the confidence of Elections Act of
1877 which is still good law was next on
the docket to be considered when Pelosi
declared an emergency what does it say
it says the vice president of the United
States shall not certify the purported
Electoral College results when there is
evidence of a lack of public confidence
in the
validity or etc etc the proceeds so said
president vice president shall call upon
Congress to appoint a 15-man committee
fir from the house fired from the Senate
fired from the US Supreme Court over
these proceedings the chief chief
justice shall preside wherein they shall
conduct an independent audit of the
election uh results taking at least 10
days or as long thereafter as is
necessary hell he was calling on the man
to follow the damn law that's still on
the
books now you indict somebody for
following the law cuz you a stupid jerk
who didn't pay any damn attention in law
school first
year do you think it sticks judge what
they're what they're trying to do with
all these cases does it does it stick to
make him unrunnable
no I I think it's motivating people hell
if I didn't like him I'd be prone to say
hell you going to dump on somebody like
that maybe I need to find out why
they're so scared of them because I
don't like the people that are acting
that way they act like what the
hell's going on and see I've been
looking at this for 50 years counselor
approach the bench State approach what
Madame court reporter please turn the
record what what the hell do you think
you'll doing it is Sir do you think
there's one charge that stands out above
all the charges that may hold him
culpable in law is there one thing that
sticks out I don't think there's one
that actually would stick if it went up
to an appell IT Court I don't see
anything he's done wrong even if you
take everything the state or the
government federal government and states
and federal government are alleging it's
subject to what in old law used to be a
demurrer you honor uh defense moves for
dismissal on the basis of a demur to it
even if everything the prosecution is
claiming is in fact true it doesn't
State a
crime so there's where you go with that
and the other thing is it's just
absolutely intolerable for these folk to
try to lapse back to
1932 and imposed the methodology of the
National Socialist Workers Party party
the German acronym for National
Socialist Workers Party is n a zi Nazi
and that's exactly what they're doing
they're trying to thwart the will of the
American public and that's why we have
the Bill of Rights the first 10
amendments to keep that from happening
you do not want to use the
prosecutorial power of the state for
political purposes to oppress repress in
intrude in or unduly influence the will
of the people is there any precedent for
any sort of counter suing for election
interference that Trump can do uh he
might and see one of the prospects I
thought about is somebody hot shot in
the house that's now under Republican
control can simply call some hearings
and call Trump as a witness as a
technical whistleblower in everything he
testifies to then becomes immune for
prosecution cuz at this point judge this
is this is election interference he is
the number one front runner for the
Republican party all these charges are
are are AEM that's and he's he's in
trouble with all the January 6 and not
trusting the electoral process this is
them actively cheating in front of our
face exactly in other words wait a
minute what the hell is going on I don't
care what the devil you say Trump did
what are you doing yeah and there you go
that ler too evils but let's get back to
something let's take Memphis and Shelby
County for example uh 19 in 2006 the
justice department found that the voting
machines uh former debal voting machines
were hopelessly
corrupted and that there was no fair
election that could be had in Memphis
and Shelby County Tennessee 2008 the
justice department put up the money to
replace every machine that was from
confiscated drug funds well each year
each quarter thereafter they gave an
update and it wasn't until November
2022 that Shelby County actually
replaced those machines so the
interesting thing is is in January when
the justice department comes out with
this thing about there was no
discernable election fraud in the
country they turned right around in the
same damn week they say in Shelby County
once again there was no fair election
etc etc because of now either you're
telling the truth about there's no
discernable election fraud in the
country in January
2021 are you lying when you turn around
in the same damn week and saying the
14th largest city in the country there's
election fraud now which is it MH you
see that looks like like orwellian
doubles be out of
1984 it's crap and by the way the other
thing too I would suggest if anybody
wants to get a grip on what's going on
take a read of Orwell's Animal Farm or
if you're too lazy Google it there is an
animal farm from 1952 it's an animation
that the CIA put out that's almost word
for word following Orwell's books and
essentially what happens is the animals
have a revolution take over a farm throw
the humans out and they come up with an
animal set of Rights all animals are
equal but the pigs uh coate with the
dogs very good book and they started
imposing a tyranny and then they have a
little modification all animals are
equal but pigs are more equal than
others yeah
snowball yeah so snowball yeah I
remember reading the book yeah so how
how do you how do you feel about uh the
the prospects of a President Joe Biden
or maybe if he doesn't run a president I
know you're a big fan of Camala Harris
or a Nome or some of the others so on
the Democratic side what what do you
think is going to end up happening there
that's a
disaster Camala Harris was used to
hiking her him line up when she wanted
to get something done in California but
she can't handle the complexity she's
too damn lazy she won't listen to her
briefings and her staff she embarrasses
the hell out of the country when she
does that hyena grin and giggle and she
starts what do the Europeans call it
word Sal claims to be black and that's a
lie I met a daddy one time down in
Jamaica with my wife we were guest of
the governor general then and he got
introduced to us as everybody's favorite
Hindu Professor now he has a grandmother
go to the picture to see what he he has
a grandmother
that's him he has a
grandmother who is supposedly according
to him a Hindu
housekeeper according to Kamala that
great grandmother her of hers is a black
woman but even if you took the picture
through the complexion she's not
completely black so in a lot of places
in the United States if you were only
one e black that didn't make you black
because that one drop rule for most of
the Confederate States wouldn't even
apply so what we have here is somebody
who had no African ancestry who is just
a
Hindu of the Tamil group who happen to
be a people that's very dark and swarthy
is being perpetrated is being black now
when I had my show the first couple of
years there were a couple of very
beautiful black women I thought worked
for the show well one of them said you
think I'm a black woman don't you I said
aren't you she says no I'm a Hindu she
said my mother was of the Brahman cast
my father was of the warrior cast he
took an oath to protect my mother but
they fell in love they went off and God
and a loped and we can't go back India
because the family put out a death
warrant on us or hit on us so I said wow
and then through her I ran into in fact
some books have been written on Hindus
who cut their hair and passed for black
to get the fellowships now she's lying
about something else during her debates
with uh senile uh Biden
when they were both running for
president she accused him of not
understanding something how when she was
an elementary school student in San
Francisco she says she was one of those
who had to be busted because of the
integration plans well she published
some years ago her High School
yearbook and High School yearbook from a
Canadian High School says from
kindergarten through 12th grade she was
a student in Canada so she's either
lying about that get out of here and
that's in her yearbook or she lying
about being a student in the Bay Area
now my former in-laws were from the Bay
Area and it's
interesting what goes on my ex-wife
beautiful as she was she was fine Lord
she was fine expensive but you
know whatever went broke in that
California divorce for 4 and A2 years no
prenup but anyway oh man she was born in
the same hospital as Cala in the same
year as Kamala and my late mother-in-law
her mama who was a Canadian citizen um
was a pediatric nurse in that same
Hospital well my ex needed a new birth
certificate so we ordered one so I know
what they look like well Calas that she
submitted to Howard University that got
released while she was running for stuff
in California it's interesting it says
nationality of mother it says British
Commonwealth it
says race of mother it says Caucasian
says religion of mother it says
Hindu for father it
says nationality is blank and then for
race it says
Jamaican so Jamaican is not a race and I
am personally acquainted with at least
one blond haired blueeyed English
aristocrat whose parents are peers in
England one's redhead and gray eyed and
the other one's blond haired blueeyed
and all three of them were born in
Jamaica and they're Jamaican citizens
and they can speak the pis as good as
anybody else who's part of the
Commonwealth so you don't have to be of
African descent to be born in Jamaica
and I've been there so many times that
they J BR you are Jamaican you like to
come to Jamaica man the blood clot Bo I
don't know you look like you be down
from C
eleish so so what you're saying is if if
she's if K is if if you say actually
she's just Indian then that that that
status or that accomplishment of the
first African vice president it's still
up for gra it's still up for
grabo so somebody else could still get
that spot yeah sure it's same thing with
Obama the first black American well yeah
technically I guess but uh he has no
mama no daddy no aunts no uncles no
grandparents that went through the black
experience in the United States of
America now I'm 76 but I can remember my
mother used to be a librarian with tusy
Institute uh I remember one time when I
was five we were driving from there
during the summer to visit some of her
relatives uh in Jackson Tennessee and we
made a mistake of starting off too early
those days if you were black you
traveled at night and slept during the
day it just wasn't
safe uh and
anyhow old man had this olive green
doodo and my mother was fishing in the
glove compartment and she asked me
sitting in the back to hold her
Coke so she loved her Cokes coca colola
so I've got the bottle sitting on my
knee
and bottle shatters and then I hear The
Gunshot and there's Coke all over my leg
and I'm looking at this Bullet Hole my
old man would decorated he was at best
stone in World War II he was telling me
about it so I said somebody shot at us
he said I know my mother said son just
get out on the floor she was calm so I'm
more worried about her getting mad at me
cuz I broke her bottle of cocacola you
know but anyway see Obama has nobody in
his family that went through anything
like
that and it's kind of
crazy uh what the problem is I'll go to
another one uh birth gate the
Constitution of the United States to
find citizenship in two places one of
them he qualifies all he has to have is
an American parent he can be born
anywhere in the world he's American
citizen the other one is a little bit
more interesting it deals with running
for president or vice president you have
to be born on American soil State
territory
protectorate military Naval based
consulate or
Embassy bad news Republican party Cruz
does not qualify cuz he was bragging
about being born in Canada that
disqualifies you if you read The
Federalist Papers they tell you they
don't want any sleepers sneaking in and
taking control of the government see so
you have to be born on American soil
cilant and embassies have a lot of
things where women rush to have their
children there when they can't get back
so they could qualify for that we have a
very interesting person everybody's
heard of Winston Churchill he was an
American citizen because his mother was
from Chicago an American ays and his
father was an English
Lord uh he' announced renounced his
citizenship so he could become Sir
Winston uh because America does not
allow ennoblement under the Constitution
but he was an American citizen that's
one of the reasons he had such a fan
club but he couldn't run for American
President because he wasn't born on
American soil now if you there you go it
was just up there if you are born in
American
Samoa the Canal Zone Puerto
Rico uh you can run for president but
now here's the
problem uh Obama released a birth
certificate when he was enrolled in
college and it list on there the room
number the phone number of the
pediatrician who did the uh delivery
they noted his mother was 18 years 3
months which meant she got knocked up at
17 and she was a citizen of Canada and
it list all of the details the phone
numbers were working on so that's one
birth certificate but he's in the white
house for 18 months before he gets one
from havai now the problem with that I
see is two people that were on my show
worked were worked on my show first
couple of years were from haai and they
needed the
passport uh because they were going to
take a trip so I'm in my office in the
headquarters for the show and I made the
phone call to the Department of Vital
Statistics in Hawaii and had them
expedite the delivery and they got their
birth certificates in 48 hours so if I
can do that back in 2000 to hell with
the president of the United States
taking 18 months to do it see I don't
buy it the other thing too is where he
went to school now 20 some years ago
more than 20 my now ex-wife wanted me to
send my oldest son to one of the same
places over there in fact the same place
he went to school and when I checked I
said this boy is not earn this because
the tuition not including room and board
was
$95,000 a year and I talked to two
people one of whom worked out in
Hollywood and one I met in Hawaii
sometime ago who bragged about going to
school with Obama and they said the
tuition when they went there with him
was 45,000 a year not including room and
board little rich kid so his father L
storo was an interesting person he was
executive International Executive Vice
President for Standard Oil he also that
guy on the left this apparently Obama's
father you're saying this is his adopted
father who adopted him when he was about
2 years old now now
he is an interesting
person he also was a major in the
Indonesian Army from 58 to 1962 or three
and he ran the death squad so there was
allegedly a warrant out for him from the
ha for Mass murdering or being
responsible for killing a half million
people back in the late 50s when he ran
to death squads we studied this
in comparative international law back in
the late 60s I remember that guy I had
no idea he was connected but anyway as
vice president for standard oil at the
time in question it was believed that
Indonesia set on the world's largest oil
Reserve so Standard Oil wanted to get
into that but they couldn't under
American law so they propped up their
vice
president financially he ran to death
squads had a lot of muscles so he wound
up becoming the oil tycoon for Indonesia
and when he died he was one of the
richest men on earth now he supposedly
died from the cumulative effects of
three separate automobile accidents
which basically came from the fact he
was a master spy the US protected him
because at the time he was running the
Spy operations for the CIA as a
contractor in China
North Korea North Vietnam Cambodia and
la and remember the NS going on at this
point in time George Herbert Walker
Bush ran the CIA under the Ford
Administration and George Herbert Walker
Bush was cousin to his wife Obama's
mother and and Obama's mother's father
Obama's maternal grandmother was first
cousin to George Herbert Walker Bush so
the family relationship in there they
all had fun and games
from uh Bush's experience with his uh
CIA connections when he ran to
CIA in loo sooro and also through
through his second cousin who was
married to him and also through the
father-in-law to sooro who was his first
cousin so it's an interesting little
filial family relationship that they
have sir does this all date back to the
Sam hinley situation you brought up Sam
hinley so what the hell is going on here
by the way he's I mean this is I could
sit here all day and I vote for him he
should run for president 1 million per
so here's the other thing they want to
get another one yeah Brad Pit is a
cousin to these guys now now where
Hollywood's involved CIA President
office Warren Buffett is a cousin this
here this is a connection Sam inkley had
some sperm that had a cap everyone
had a cape you know Obama and Brad Pit
are cousins ninth cousins to be precise
on the campaign Trail last year to
merged at the two Shar common ancestor
Edward Hinman who died in Virginia is
that part of the sand
come so so basically judge they're all
connected so no matter what these guys
are they run the show they're all
connected you see this thing where
Michelle and George W get the giglet and
he get the candy what I hear from the
inside sources is that the same candy
that he used to give to her husband when
he was a kid now there's a picture I
stumbled on to that you could Google but
you can't now and when I ran into it he
was still in uh uh Illinois in the state
house and what that was about was
there's a picture where Lolo satoro is
standing up with a golf club George W
bush Herbert Walker
Bush soon to be president of the United
States is standing up with a golf club
and then sitting in a golf cart with his
arm around a 7even eighty old kid
standing next to it is georan W bush and
the kid is uh loo soro's adopted kid
Barry Soro soon to be Barack Obama wow
so so are you saying that Obama met the
bushes when he was a kid yeah they grew
up together they used to hang around
that's wild that's wild so I mean it
ain't like this is just somebody they
met at some White House ceremony they
this is family I got one more for you
sir since you know Buffett in there too
he's one of them as well you said that
you can't lie between what's in between
your thighs what do you know about
Michelle Obama that we don't know what
you heard don't know but there's one
picture you flashed up there that they
have a copy of in the white house which
one I D my mind is fullon blown right
now my brains are against the wall right
now which which picture judge there's
one that's in the white house now they
attended a ceremony a couple of years
ago where is it I think I saw it in
there and who is this one Barack Obama
yeah and all of that Barack Obama and
Michelle I don't know what she is do you
think she's going to run judge you hope
not that's a waste but I tell you one
thing that I don't like about Barack
Obama there was an incident in caprini
green some projects highrise projects
now torn down in Chicago there was an
old lady in her 90s in a
wheelchair and some gangsters broke into
her apartment and they had been raping
and robbing women in these apartments
now she had a single action C 45 a
peacemaker that
her late husband a cowboy had left
her and she shot several of the people
that had broken in well she got
prosecuted at the time under Chicago Law
for having an unregistered
firearm there was a special act in front
of the Illinois state legislature to
Grant her immunity and it was unanimous
with one hold out and that person was
Barack Obama wow I didn't like him ever
since then now there's another guy that
was the congressman from the district he
ran
for uh Bobby Rush who was a former Black
Panther
and I
did get a chance to see the tape of that
in uh Rush embarrassed the hell out of
Obama who knew absolutely nothing about
the area he was running from it was this
thing he was
representing uh real estate developer
the law firm was now he comes from good
Republican stock
Obama The Firm he and Michelle work for
is one of the oldest Republican law
firms in America and in fact they helped
finance Abraham Lincoln's first run for
president so the toilet paper I guess
has elephants printed on it but you know
wipe your ass with the the elephant you
know I guess pretty committed so
interestingly enough to show you Obama's
fraud the Heritage Foundation which gets
into stuff pretty deep you've heard of
them all right course yes they do a
report card every year on the
representatives in the house and the
Senate and they gave Obama two years
running their third highest rating a 96
plus percent second place man got a
little higher plus percent and the first
one got
97% correct voting for conservative
causes when he was a US senator which
certainly doesn't fit his Persona
because he's an opportunist he had the
lowest voting record out of the hundred
Senators but it is what it is uh so you
don't know where the hell he's coming
from and I guess that's because of his
family spy background spies aren't known
for telling the truth I mean you get
caught damn if you did yeah but speaking
of which I want to get off into another
thing I just thought about it this thing
that Biden is talking about it's a done
deal for DC to get stat Hood now I was
born in Washington DC
disclaimer so I guess I'm a native
but DC does not need a state Hood it's a
relatively smaller middle siiz American
city about 300 some thousand people and
if you want the citizens the residence
of what's now the District of Colombia
to be able to get adequate voting
representation in Congress Your solution
is
simply uh to return it to Maryland and
keep the Capital Mall as the district
where nobody lives except the president
vice president so then they can get
representation they can vote in Congress
because otherwise all you're doing is
giving this
300,000 plus population city the clout
of a state and when you go to DC right
now they've gentrified the place and
it's a rainbow City so that would give
the cult the clout of a whole state for
living in a mediumsized city which is
inappropriate that's just a Dodge but
that's the poison on that to give them
their votes simply seed the damn
District back to Maryland where it came
from in the first damn place place and
they can get representation they can
vote now that just thought I throw that
in I have one last question for I know
we got to wrap up what's it going to
take for you to call yourself a
republican because I think I just became
a conservative literally on this podcast
swear to God well I could become a
republican if the people in charge start
dealing with recognizing their
opportunity what the hell look at all
the people out out there that want an
alternative who are family people who
appreciate manhood who appreciate duty
honor obligation character being about
something earning your own damn way in
life instead of whining about what's
coming down on your shoulders yeah it's
it's it's adversity but you can go out
and kick his ass you know you can go
back face real quick I would vote if if
for some reason Trump can't run and
everybody else falls out I would vote
for you 100 I would I by the way he's
younger than Trump and Biden I love it
just to be clear couple years love it
Joe Brown uh this has been fantastic I
think next time we do it I don't think
two hours is enough I honestly we got to
go three hours next I'll bring up let's
get some barbecue sauce and by the way
we may even do the next one live with an
audience because I think the audience
would love it we'll do at the comedy
club so Judge Joe Brown thank you so
much for I do a little of that too
love it some British accent
fantastic really enjoyed it thank you so
much for coming out cannot wait to do
this again next time is Rob is there a
website is there somewhere where people
can is there anything you're working on
here here if you want to get me I do X
that's at Judge Joe Brown TV following
you right now I do there you go uh let's
see well I don't know about more
executive vanish in China but I like
that where instead of getting being
Crooks instead of getting a $5 million
book deal then you get a wall that you
can prop up
for brief while until you slide off okay
yeah there you go go give the judge a
follow Rob that link below give him a
follow and also for those RFK I think
VIP and Premier tickets are sold there's
some general tickets I believe left
December 6 town hall with RFK 2 to4 uh
it happens to fall on the same day as
the debate for GOP in Alabama which
means some of the things he says that
day could cause a little bit of you know
what I'm saying for some of you guys
that got VIP tickets you'll get a chance
to ask him questions as well text award
podcast to
31034 11132 again 3103 41132 or go to
5990 live.com to register for the
podcast two other things I have to
mention uh I do Monday and Thursday with
the real Dana you can catch us on YouTu
when they're not censoring us too badly
and also we do a Twitter space on X uh
every Tuesday and then locally she's a
fine young lady Valerie Denise Jones we
do the Judge Joe Brown radio thing it's
syndicated we do that on uh Friday so
you can check that out don't forget you
again take care Everybody by bar sauuce
don't forget the sauce
but